oh what's going on oh you know just tell
me everything hanging out hustling life
good yeah life is good yes
i'm uh freaking out about your new show
and i want to get into it's really fun
oh you really go for it i'm i'm a dark
little lady i'm getting like sharon
stone basic instincts not because of the
sexiness but that like iconic
femme
will stop at nothing
take over your your like old hollywood
in this show
it's um
thank you
it's just such an extraordinary meaty
performance and you go for it and stop
at nothing thank you i really appreciate
that it felt it was so fun to do like i
had so much fun
being so not fun now i happen to see on
your instagram page there's someone very
special in your instagram world and in
your life i know you guys don't know
with you everywhere oh there he is will
you please explain the history of
tino tina
yeah
um
well
i think my mom must have gotten me this
when i was i i don't know five or six
just to do makeup on and and
went dark for years didn't didn't see
him but then
i was maybe maybe like 13 or 14 and my
friends and i were in the basement one
day and we we dragged him up unearthed
unearthed
and you know fresh-faced
and and we just sort of started taking
him around and we thought it was really
funny and we bring him everywhere and it
kind of just stuck and tino became a
fixture and tino has like
performed like he's posed with coal
sprouts oh yeah he's he's um he hobnobs
with the best of them yeah there he is
with coal
has
tino ever been he's very charismatic
i mean that's literally like the it boy
of the century yeah and there's tina
with him has tino ever been on like a i
don't know say a
daytime television show well no but
there's a first for everything is tino
can he come out
he might be here
he might be here
well
i i might have someone for tino if tina
wants to make an appearance oh do you
yeah really really ready yeah one two
three
oh my god
[Applause]
um
now i would like to introduce tino
to wait
tina oh beautiful
oh this is a love story i mean this is
amazing
i love this
this is adorable well
maybe they could go on a date after the
show i think it's and start getting
their chemistry on yeah they could hit
up a nice little they could have a nice
little lunch somewhere shall we get them
ready for their dates
now i can't not ask about
literally one of the most important
shows in television history it deserves
its own television and radio museum
yeah
[Applause]
what
was i mean did you guys have fun on the
set give us a fly on the wall
anything on the best show ever made i
had so much fun
i love that cast so much and i mean it's
crazy i grew up on it right i was six
when i started and 15 when we wrapped oh
that's cute i mean look at that and now
i run into john hamm so much
i was at i was i was at dinner a couple
weeks ago with my friends and john was a
couple tables over having like a
peaceful nice dinner and my friends and
i were getting a little rowdy and we
thought it'd be really funny to start
airdropping people photos in the
restaurant
like really stupid memes and stuff and
my friend airdropped a photo and he goes
oh no i accidentally just airdropped
something to john hamm
and
john accepted john accepted the photos
and then he sort of like then they left
and we never we never had a clarifying
moment i love that i mean he's a fun guy
everyone wants to have fun
play i'm all about a sense of play
that's what it is it's playful that's
why i like that do you guys ever talk
about a mad men reunion or like a
yeah we have a group chat that's pretty
poppin what ha what's on it
i mean it depends on the day it depends
on the day but we
once someone writes in the group chat
everyone is is all in and it's like
we're back well until that reunion
happens it's so nice to know that
everybody's still talking at least we
can fantasize about that
[Applause]
if they were to do one would you play oh
i would i'd play a harpy any day gosh
let's do a madman reunion
[Applause]
no i want to i would any day the people
are hungry for it is it true that you're
also like a black yes i'm a black one
taekwondo
that's the specific martial art that i'm
a black bell then oh my god
how wow how well i just
i signed up for a million things when i
was a kid and that was one of the things
that stuck i mean
[Applause]
like i was stressed that that was my
black belt that was my test for a black
let's see i'm wearing a little red belt
there you're breaking like a brick i'm
breaking a brick
breaking a brick they call me brick
breaker break breakers
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay i am very excited to reveal yeah
i've come out
you know i'm so wrapped in our
conversation i'm hoping that he likes
what he sees
so that maybe we can
make them instagram friends
i'm ready oh okay good okay okay oh my
god oh yeah
[Applause]
yeah that actually worked
oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
wait
[Music]
i feel this couple this is such a fish
they're like sexy and cute this is a hot
couple
new couple alerts oh my god spotted
[Music]